Tasha: OK了
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 来露西开始了吧
Jake: Alright Lucia, let's get started.
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, good, good.
Jake: 那我们后边先看
Jake: Let's watch the back first.
Alice:耶
Alice: Yay!
Alice: 看这个好茂盛
Alice: Look at how lush this is.
Lucia: 我说好的
Lucia: I said it's good.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 他真好
Alice: He's really nice.
Tasha: 这头一个
Tasha: This is the first one.
Jake: 好我们有很多东西
Jake: Okay, we have a lot of stuff.
Jake: 稍等一下
Jake: Wait a minute.
Alice: 这是别人那啥的
Alice: This is what others...
Alice:有门
Alice: There's a door.
Tasha: 别人的庄园
Tasha: Someone else's estate.
Alice: 走下车吧
Alice: Let's get out of the car.
Lucia: 哇这个真的好重
Lucia: Wow, this is really heavy.
Lucia: 要不可能里面饮料比较多
Lucia: Maybe there are a lot of drinks inside.
Jake: 我来吧
Jake: Let me do it.
Lucia: 这个，还能拿动吗
Lucia: Can you still carry this?
Tasha: 眼睛头疼不疼
Tasha: Do your eyes hurt?
Tasha: 小心点啊
Tasha: Be careful.
Tasha: 他他的摄像头
Tasha: His camera.
Jake: 我我我头疼
Jake: I, I have a headache.
Jake:还有
Jake: Also...
Alice: 还有
Alice: Also...
Alice: 还有我们的司机  跟蒜苗
Alice: There's our driver and the garlic chives.
Tasha: 哎我我
Tasha: Oh, I...
Jake: 好谢谢谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you, thank you.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 没没没掉吧
Lucia: No, it didn't fall.
Tasha: 哎蒜
Tasha: Oh, garlic.
Alice: 哎呀这个不是我们的吧
Alice: Oh, this isn't ours, right?
Tasha: 不是都不是了
Tasha: No, none of it is.
Alice: 哦走吧OK
Alice: Oh, let's go, okay.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 我想说
Tasha: I want to say...
Tasha: 怎么开商务座的都要打领带
Tasha: Why do people who drive business class have to wear ties?
Tasha: 穿皮裤啊
Tasha: And leather pants?
Tasha: 哦不，穿，穿西装裤
Tasha: Oh no, wearing, wearing suit pants.
Alice: 我觉得这个小紫花也可以
Alice: I think this little purple flower is also fine.
Tasha: 显得很
Tasha: It looks very...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 你看挺好看的
Alice: Look, it's quite pretty.
Tasha: 是的嘞
Tasha: Yes, indeed.
Alice:他把我这个偷
Alice: He stole this from me.
Alice: 呃拿花
Alice: Uh, picked the flower.
Alice:给记录下来了
Alice: And recorded it.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Alice: 没关系这个数据就是
Alice: It's okay, this data is just...
Alice: 狗狗碎碎的
Alice: Dog bits and pieces.
Tasha: 呃前面一个吧
Tasha: Uh, the one in front.
Tasha: 这个像那棵树的那个地方
Tasha: This one is like the place by that tree.
Alice:你这个小花妆起来好好看啊
Alice: Your little flower makeup looks so nice.
Tasha: 嗯哼哼
Tasha: Hmm hmm hmm.
Tasha: 很多
Tasha: A lot.
Katrina:  就是那个海报
Katrina: It's that poster.
Katrina:  我搜到的都是网盘
Katrina: All I found were cloud drives.
Katrina:  就是那种虚拟的
Katrina: Just those virtual ones.
Katrina:  那就是自己打印呗
Katrina: So just print it yourself.
Jake: 哦哦哦OK啊
Jake: Oh oh oh, okay.
Jake: 可以啊你
Jake: You can do it.
Alice: 们的房子不是绿色的吗
Alice: Isn't our house green?
Tasha: 蓝色吗？
Tasha: Blue?
Tasha: 蓝绿色
Tasha: Blue-green.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Alice: 这个颜色吗
Alice: This color?
Tasha: 前面这个
Tasha: The one in front.
Tasha: 但感觉又走错了
Tasha: But feels like we went the wrong way.
Alice: 你们不应该是从那个吗
Alice: Shouldn't you have come from that way?
Jake: 对和昨天一样
Jake: Yes, same as yesterday.
Jake: 里边水比较重是吧
Jake: There's more water inside, right?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 我得稍薇放一下调整一下我的手
Lucia: I need to slightly adjust my hand.
Jake: 要不我们极限一换一
Jake: How about we do an extreme one-for-one?
Jake: 我们极限一换一
Jake: We'll do an extreme one-for-one.
Lucia: 哎你一只手提这个
Lucia: Hey, you carry this with one hand.
Jake: 我试一下我试一下我试一下
Jake: I'll try it, I'll try it, I'll try it.
Lucia: 会不会太重了
Lucia: Won't it be too heavy?
Jake: 好奇一下这个有多重
Jake: I'm curious, how heavy is this?
Lucia: 真的真的很重
Lucia: Really, really heavy.
Tasha: 你健身吗
Tasha: Do you work out?
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Jake:撞到你头了
Jake: Did it hit your head?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 咱俩都在头疼一下了
Lucia: We both got a bit of a headache now.
Lucia: 是吧这件事有点
Lucia: Right, this is a bit...
Jake: 不是不是这个
Jake: No, no, not this one.
Lucia: 要不你把这个袋子给我们俩
Lucia: How about you give us this bag?
Jake: 你你你
Jake: You, you, you...
Lucia: 能提动那个吗
Lucia: Can you lift that?
Jake: 你可能
Jake: You might...
Jake: 你可能觉得这个好像比这个更重
Jake: You might think this one is heavier.
Lucia: 是这样吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Lucia: 这个好像也挺重的
Lucia: This one seems pretty heavy too.
Lucia: 是的但好像比刚那个稍薇好一点点
Lucia: Yes, but it seems a tiny bit better than the last one.
Jake: OK行
Jake: OK, fine.
Lucia: 走咱加快步伐
Lucia: Let's pick up the pace.
Jake: 极限一换一
Jake: Extreme one-for-one.
Alice: 这个给我吧
Alice: Give me this one.
Lucia: 谢谢您辛苦了
Lucia: Thank you, you worked hard.
Jake: 健身我是两年前健
Jake: I started working out two years ago.
Jake: 我到新加坡之后就不健了
Jake: I stopped when I moved to Singapore.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Alice:右右右
Alice: Right, right, right.
Jake: 右边右边啊
Jake: To the right, to the right.
Lucia: 因为工作比较忙嘛
Lucia: Because work got busier, right?
Jake: 因为健身房有点远啊
Jake: And the gym is quite far away.
Jake: 就是作为一个批人吧
Jake: As a lazy person...
Jake: 就健身房他不在楼底下我应该很难去
Jake: If the gym isn't downstairs, it's hard for me to go.
Lucia: 任何东西不离我很近我一般都很难去
Lucia: If anything isn't really close, I generally find it hard to go.
Jake: 在这个里边
Jake: In here.
Tasha: 应该把小米装
Tasha: Should put the millet in.
Tasha: 装小米烤箱的那个袋子带着的
Tasha: The bag that came with the Xiaomi oven.
Jake: 什么袋子
Jake: What bag?
Tasha: 那个大袋子啊
Tasha: That big bag.
Jake: 还有个线是吧
Jake: There's a cord, right?
Alice: 小狗
Alice: Little dog.
Tasha: 哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Alice: 他作作作
Alice: He's just faking it.
Alice: 他就他就过来看你
Alice: He just came over to see you.
Tasha: 然后你也不喂他吃的
Tasha: And you didn't even feed him.
Alice: 这个啧啧啧
Alice: This is just... ugh.
Alice: 像他喝奶的声音
Alice: Like the sound when he drinks milk.
Alice: 所以他又过来了
Alice: So he came over again.
Tasha: 好重啊受不了了
Tasha: So heavy, I can't take it.
Tasha: 哦好吧你东西也好多
Tasha: Oh, well, you have so much stuff.
Alice: 东西我换一个
Alice: I'll change it.
Tasha: 没关系走少了一个人就是很困难啊
Tasha: It's okay, it's just really hard when there's one less person.
Alice: 行说我
Alice: Alright, tell me.
Lucia: 我们的有有密码吗
Lucia: Do we have a password?
Jake: 有密码但是我记不住
Jake: There's a password, but I can't remember it.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, haha.
Lucia: 那您来说
Lucia: Then you tell me.
Jake: 我要查一下手机
Jake: I need to check my phone.
Jake: 这个时候手机如果能告诉你
Jake: If only my phone could tell me right now.
Tasha: 但但我记住了
Tasha: But, but I remembered it.
Tasha: 你不是这么说的吗
Tasha: Didn't you say it like this?
Lucia: 啊她说的好像是你
Lucia: Ah, she said it was like you.
Jake: 哦但他说的好像是但他记住了
Jake: Oh, but he said he remembered it.
Jake: 哈哈我没有记住
Jake: Haha, I didn't remember it.
Lucia: 这个要是有语音功能就好了
Lucia: It would be great if this had a voice function.
Lucia: 对问问他
Lucia: Yeah, ask it.
Lucia: 我发现这个摄像头会发出彩虹光哎
Lucia: I noticed this camera makes rainbow lights.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 再再再摁一次那个3
Jake: Press the 3 again.
Jake: 那个3再摁一下
Lucia: 那我我
Lucia: Then I...
Jake:三三
Jake: Three, three.
Lucia: 怎样能把它删掉
Lucia: How can I delete it?
Jake: 不就不用
Jake: No, you don't need to.
Jake: 不用重来
Jake: No need to restart.
Jake: 就就是你直接重来就行
Jake: Just start over directly.
Jake: 他就算最后一位
Jake: He counts as the last digit.
Lucia: 925 对OK
Lucia: 925, right, OK.
Alice: 这是他的猫
Alice: This is his cat.
Tasha: 往里面放一点
Tasha: Put it a bit further in.
Tasha: 哇这个真的来放不了了
Tasha: Wow, this really can't fit anymore.
Lucia: 您的卧室真的很赛博是吧
Lucia: Your bedroom is really cyber, isn't it?
Jake: 晚上就是这个样子
Jake: It looks like this at night.
Jake: 因为怕这个关掉之后数据就倒不过去
Jake: Because if I turn it off, the data won't transfer.
Jake: 对就得开着
Jake: Yeah, so it has to stay on.
Jake: 然后突然惊醒的看一眼哦
Jake: Then suddenly I wake up and check, oh,
Jake: 还在传哈哈哈
Jake: it's still transferring, hahaha.
Lucia: 我可以在你的小桌子上玩2077吗
Lucia: Can I play 2077 on your small table?
Lucia: 哈哈沉浸式玩游戏
Lucia: Haha, immersive gaming.
Jake: 是
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  我要记一下我们还有什么东西没买
Katrina: I need to note down what we haven't bought yet.
Katrina:  笔呢
Katrina: Where's the pen?
Tasha: 我们先把要放进冰箱的挑出来
Tasha: Let's first pick out what needs to go in the fridge.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 吧
Tasha: Right.
Katrina:  这个笔呢
Katrina: Where's the pen?
Katrina:  谁看见了
Katrina: Who saw it?
Jake: 笔我带上去了我
Jake: I took the pen upstairs.
Jake: 再带上去
Jake: I'll take it again.
Lucia: 哪瓶水是我的来着
Lucia: Which bottle of water is mine?
Tasha: 呦这这对
Tasha: Oh, this one, right.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Mmm.
Lucia: 咦
Lucia: Eh?
Tasha:是吧
Tasha: Right?
Lucia: 什么情况啊
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake: 啊这个要不砍了吧
Jake: Ah, should we cut this?
Lucia: 对他好像打不开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems it won't open.
Jake: 买一个大刀把它给剪了
Jake: Buy a big knife and cut it.
Lucia: 哦开了开了
Lucia: Oh, it opened.
Lucia: 有点紧那个
Lucia: It was a bit tight.
Lucia: 记得
Lucia: Remember.
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Tasha: 水果水果放一起
Tasha: Fruits go together.
Tasha: 蔬菜放一起对
Tasha: Vegetables go together, right.
Lucia: 没开封的饮料其实可以先放在外面
Lucia: Unopened drinks can actually stay outside.
Lucia: 是咱们现在因为东西比较多就不要
Lucia: Since we have a lot of stuff now, let's not.
Alice: 楼上是不是还有热不要钱
Alice: Is there still heat upstairs for free?
Katrina:  那我把对饮料放楼上去
Katrina: Then I'll put the drinks upstairs.
Lucia: 楼上有个冰箱
Lucia: There's a fridge upstairs.
Jake: 等一下先
Jake: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 先把先把先把必须放冰箱的放进去
Lucia: First, put the things that must go in the fridge.
Jake:先把冰放进去
Jake: First, put the ice in.
Lucia: 然后再考虑别的
Lucia: Then we can think about other stuff.
Lucia: 冰
Lucia: Ice.
Jake:就是要放冰冻的
Jake: We need to put the frozen stuff in.
Jake: 冷冻的哦
Jake: The frozen ones.
Katrina:  还有个蓝莓是吗
Katrina: There's also some blueberries, right?
Katrina:  冷冻啊这个是需要放冰箱的
Katrina: This needs to go in the fridge, it's frozen.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: And there's a box of strawberries.
Tasha: 啊哦在这
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 哦吓我一跳
Tasha: Oh, it scared me.
Katrina:  这个是必须放冰箱的
Katrina: This definitely needs to go in the fridge.
Lucia: 这个是放冷藏室
Lucia: This goes in the refrigerator.
Lucia: 冷冻室
Lucia: Freezer section.
Katrina: 冷藏吧
Katrina: Fridge, right?
Katrina:  冷冻冷藏
Katrina: Freezer or fridge.
Alice:冷藏
Alice: Fridge.
Alice: 冻冻这个冷藏有0度吗
Alice: Does the fridge have a 0-degree section?
Alice: 我怎么感觉这温度不太够
Alice: I feel like the temperature isn't enough.
Katrina:  我把饮料挤入哎
Katrina: I'm squeezing the drinks in.
Jake: 你们不是有那个测温的吗
Jake: Don't you guys have a thermometer?
Jake: 测温有用吗
Jake: Is the thermometer useful?
Tasha: 要要干嘛
Tasha: For what?
Jake: 测冰箱多少度
Jake: To measure the fridge's temperature.
Lucia: 万一不够的话
Lucia: What if it's not enough?
Lucia: 那个肉也可以放冷冻室
Lucia: We can put the meat in the freezer.
Lucia: 然后尽快吃
Lucia: And eat it quickly.
Lucia: 只要它上面结的霜不要太多就行
Lucia: As long as there's not too much frost on it, it's fine.
Tasha: 这放两瓶鲜牛奶刚刚好
Tasha: Two bottles of fresh milk fit perfectly.
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来了
Tasha: We can take this out.
Alice: 鲜牛奶
Alice: Fresh milk.
Katrina:  这这个扔了吧
Katrina: Let's throw this away.
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来
Tasha: We can take this out.
Katrina:  烤鸭这个昨天晚上
Katrina: This roast duck from last night.
Tasha: 我天哪冰箱里面放菜说我不能接受
Tasha: Oh my god, I can't accept putting food in the fridge like this.
Katrina:  而且没有盖保鲜膜
Katrina: And without plastic wrap.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  扔了吧
Katrina: Let's throw it away.
Jake: 丢吧来
Jake: Throw it away, come on.
Katrina:  这酒啥的我放二楼吧
Katrina: I'll put the alcohol on the second floor.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  我想这一楼先做饭是在一楼吧
Katrina: I think we should cook on the first floor, right?
Katrina:  可是这样的
Katrina: But like this...
Lucia: 蛋要放冰箱吧应该
Lucia: The eggs should go in the fridge, right?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mango.
Lucia: 芒果是用来做做甜品的时候用的吗
Lucia: Is the mango for making desserts?
Jake: 呃好
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake: 是吗芒果是给人
Jake: Really? Is the mango for...
Jake: 吃的还是
Jake: ...eating or...
Tasha: 对我做甜品的
Tasha: Yeah, I use it for desserts.
Lucia: 那这个呢
Lucia: What about this?
Jake: 那为什么要6个呀
Jake: Then why do we need 6?
Tasha: 我只是觉得6个比较划算
Tasha: I just thought 6 was a better deal.
Jake: 哦我以为你数了6个人呢
Jake: Oh, I thought you counted 6 people.
Lucia: 一人一个
Lucia: One for each person.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 呃今晚就把它吃掉
Lucia: Uh, let's finish it tonight.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 那这个这个
Lucia: What about this, this...
Lucia: 这个菠萝是今天晚上吃的
Lucia: Is this pineapple for tonight?
Lucia: 还是要用的
Lucia: Or do we need to use it?
Tasha: 呃今天晚上吃的啊
Tasha: Uh, it's for tonight.
Lucia: 那要不就放外面
Lucia: Then let's just leave it out.
Lucia: 反正今天晚上要吃
Lucia: Since we're eating it tonight.
Jake: 我们点个外卖吧
Jake: Let's order takeout.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Sure.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: We still have a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:还需要
Alice: Do we still...
Alice: 还有肉吗
Alice: ...have any meat?
Tasha: 没有肉了啊
Tasha: No more meat.
Katrina:  还有虾滑
Katrina: There's still shrimp paste.
Katrina:  等一下还还有一瓶虾滑
Katrina: Wait, there's still a bottle of shrimp paste.
Katrina:  放哪里啊
Katrina: Where should we put it?
Katrina:  我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: We still have a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯啊西瓜
Lucia: Hmm, ah, watermelon.
Tasha: 牛奶
Tasha: Milk.
Alice: 就是怎么只剩一个了
Alice: Why is there only one left?
Tasha: 哎怎么只剩一瓶牛奶了啊
Tasha: Hey, why is there only one bottle of milk left?
Lucia: 那那里那里那里还有一个袋子
Lucia: There, there, there, there's another bag.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我来拿吧
Lucia: I'll get it.
Tasha: 你
Tasha: You...
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 放这的
Tasha: Put it here.
Tasha: 因为感觉这样子一定要放在一起
Tasha: Because I feel like this should be put together.
Tasha: 就会很好看
Tasha: It will look nice.
Tasha: 对所以我一直在找他
Tasha: Yeah, so I've been looking for it.
Alice:蛋是不是放这
Alice: Should the eggs go here?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:这有个蛋篓
Alice: There's an egg basket here.
Lucia: 这里还有一盒蛋
Lucia: There's another box of eggs here.
Tasha: 这盒蛋是可食用蛋
Tasha: This box of eggs is edible.
Tasha: 可生吃蛋
Tasha: Can be eaten raw.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one...
Tasha: 直接这样吧
Tasha: Just like this.
Alice: 哇哦
Alice: Wow.
Tasha: 还可以嗯
Tasha: It's okay, yeah.
Alice: 这底下我觉得可以利用一下
Alice: I think we can use the space below.
Tasha: 可以先放这
Tasha: We can put it here first.
Jake: 你们在采购之前
Jake: Before you guys shopped,
Jake: 有人仔细的看过冰箱吗
Jake: did anyone carefully check the fridge?
Katrina:  没有咋啦
Katrina: No, why?
Lucia: 但是需要的话
Lucia: But if needed,
Lucia: 咱们可以现在上仔细的看一下
Lucia: we can carefully check it now.
Lucia: 那个没用了的冰箱
Lucia: The unused fridge.
Lucia: 还没用到的冰箱啊
Lucia: The fridge we haven't used yet.
Jake: 也不用也不用
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake: 就是就就
Jake: It's just...
Tasha: 一个问卷
Tasha: A questionnaire.
Jake: 你们其实也没有看冰箱
Jake: You guys actually didn't check the fridge.
Jake: 大概也就知道怎么回事了
Jake: You probably know what's going on.
Lucia: 呃怎么回事
Lucia: Uh, what's going on?
Jake: 就是大概
Jake: Just roughly...
Jake: 呃我们装多少东西啊
Jake: Uh, how much stuff we put in.
Tasha: : 哦这个能放吗
Lucia: 有一个估算吧
Lucia: There's an estimate.
Jake: 可能有吧
Jake: Maybe there is.
Jake: 就当有吧
Jake: Let's assume there is.
Jake: 问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Lucia: 我们可以姑且认为他有
Lucia: We can just assume he has it.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这还有两盒安佳稀奶油和这个
Lucia: There are also two boxes of Anchor cream and this.
Lucia: 也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: They need to go in the fridge too, right?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 这些奶油都放这
Tasha: All the cream goes here.
Tasha: 吧你那个塞不下
Tasha: Your fridge won't fit it all.
Alice: 你搁这吧
Alice: Just put it here.
Tasha: 啊可是他应该放在那个区域
Tasha: But it should go in that section.
Alice: 没事
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 但奶油有三瓶
Tasha: But there's three bottles of cream.
Katrina:  哎三瓶吗这里面怎么感觉哎
Katrina: Huh, three bottles? How come it feels like...
Lucia: 哦哦还有一瓶耶
Lucia: Oh, there's another bottle!
Alice: 把它放这
Alice: Put it here.
Tasha: 什么还有蓝莓啊
Tasha: What, there's also blueberries?
Lucia: 这个先在这放一下吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it here for now.
Lucia: 如果不是今天晚上吃的就放到冰箱
Lucia: If we're not eating it tonight, put it in the fridge.
Jake: 吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake: 晚上吃什么呢
Jake: What are we having for dinner?
Lucia: 晚上吃什么呢
Lucia: What are we having for dinner?
Jake: 吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake: 烧烤哈哈
Jake: Barbecue, haha.
Tasha: 一定要记进去
Tasha: Make sure to note it down.
Tasha: 好就这样挤
Tasha: Okay, just squeeze it in.
Jake: 盖浇饭
Jake: Rice with toppings.
Jake: 吉野家板面
Jake: Yoshinoya noodles.
Jake: 三文鱼
Jake: Salmon.
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: All good options.
Jake:烤全鱼
Jake: Grilled whole fish.
Jake: 螺蛳粉
Jake: Snail noodles.
Lucia: 螺蛳粉咱们这个房间透气性好吗
Lucia: Snail noodles? Does this room have good ventilation?
Jake: 那确实不太好
Jake: Not really.
Jake: 蟹黄拌饭
Jake: Crab roe rice.
Jake: 肉蟹堡
Jake: Crab burgers.
Jake: 春饼
Jake: Spring pancakes.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: There's also a box of strawberries.
Lucia: 呃是不是在那里面
Lucia: Uh, is it over there?
Lucia: 没有吗
Lucia: Not there?
Lucia: 哎那那边那个也已经拿出来了
Lucia: Ah, that one over there has already been taken out too.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hot pot base.
Lucia: 倒是还有一盒蓝莓不过
Lucia: There's still a box of blueberries, though.
Tasha: 蓝莓放
Tasha: Put the blueberries.
Katrina: 在这
Katrina: Here they are.
Tasha: 我嗯还还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: I, um, also have a box of strawberries.
Katrina:  这只有一盒
Katrina: There's only one box.
Katrina: 喏，那里
Katrina: Look, over there.
Lucia: 噢
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 天呐就跟瞎了一样
Tasha: Oh my god, it's like being blind.
Katrina:  是的是的哎
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, totally.
Jake: 我们把这个灯开下来
Jake: Let's turn on this light.
Jake: 可能就少瞎一点
Jake: Maybe we'll be a little less blind.
Lucia: 哦厨房还有个灯
Lucia: Oh, there's another light in the kitchen.
Jake: 对在这边少瞎一点
Jake: Yeah, over here, we'll be a little less blind.
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great.
Tasha: 这都是调味料了
Tasha: These are all seasonings.
Alice: 调味料哎
Alice: Seasonings, huh?
Tasha: 柠檬和这个
Tasha: Lemon and this.
Alice: 下面可以放
Alice: We can put them below.
Lucia: 这个要不要拆一下
Lucia: Should we unpack this?
Lucia: 然后放这个冰箱
Lucia: And then put it in the fridge?
Tasha: 这个蔬菜
Tasha: These vegetables.
Lucia: 蔬菜也放冰箱吗
Lucia: Should the vegetables go in the fridge too?
Lucia: 今天晚上又不吃
Lucia: We're not eating them tonight.
Tasha: 还有这个
Tasha: And this one.
Tasha: 他真是一个煞风景的东西
Tasha: This thing is really a buzzkill.
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Tasha: 它
Tasha: It.
Jake:哦 这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Alice: 放常温也可以啊
Alice: It can be kept at room temperature.
Tasha: 这不放冰箱
Tasha: Not putting this in the fridge.
Jake: 对啊放外边当武器挂门上
Jake: Yeah, put it outside, hang it on the door as a weapon.
Tasha: 这个是不是也是常温就可以
Tasha: Can this also be kept at room temperature?
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个我们拿的时候是常温的
Lucia: When we got it, it was at room temperature.
Jake:对啊放外边
Jake: Yeah, put it outside.
Lucia: 你看那个密封的
Lucia: See, it's sealed.
Jake:放外边放哪呢
Jake: Where should we put it outside?
Katrina:  扔个垃圾
Katrina: Throw out the trash.
Lucia: 哎这不是垃圾桶吗
Lucia: Hey, isn't this a trash can?
Jake: 是垃圾桶
Jake: It's a trash can.
Jake: 但是 呃
Jake: But, um...
Lucia: 他他他
Lucia: He, he, he...
Alice:那个内胆
Alice: The inner liner...
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh...
Alice:用来醒花了
Alice: It's used for waking flowers.
Jake: 就这个已经被改装了
Jake: So this has been modified.
Tasha: 改良了
Tasha: Improved.
Jake:给你看
Jake: Let me show you.
Jake: 改良成那个样子
Jake: Modified like that.
Jake: 哎改良完了
Jake: Hey, it's finished.
Katrina: 我把饮料都放二楼了
Katrina: I put the drinks on the second floor.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Jake: 改完了是吧
Jake: Is it finished?
Alice: 他们用过了
Alice: They've used it.
Jake: 他们原来把这个当作
Jake: They originally used this as...
Jake: 这个装花的容器啊
Jake: A container for flowers.
Katrina:  我洗过了一点
Katrina: I washed it a bit.
Jake: 哎哎哎哎哎哎哎  呃OK
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey... Um, okay.
Jake: 现在有啊
Jake: Now we have it.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这这个魔芋丝和这些
Lucia: This konjac and these...
Lucia: 这些是不是也是放冰箱的
Lucia: These should also go in the fridge, right?
Tasha: 昂对的
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: 是的是的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 这个葱姜蒜组合放外面就行了
Tasha: This onion-ginger-garlic combo can stay outside.
Lucia: 对葱姜蒜可以放外面
Lucia: Yeah, onion-ginger-garlic can stay outside.
Lucia: 里面嗯
Lucia: Inside, um...
Lucia: 土豆呢还有这个糕点吗那是
Lucia: Potatoes and this pastry, is that...
Lucia: 两个葱姜蒜组合
Lucia: Two onion-ginger-garlic combos.
Tasha: 怕一个不够啊
Tasha: Afraid one won't be enough.
Lucia: 还有海盐
Lucia: And sea salt.
Lucia: 摇摇奶盖嗯
Lucia: Shake it, milk cap, um...
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 红薯应该是常温就可以吧
Lucia: Sweet potatoes should be fine at room temperature, right?
Lucia: 这个菜要不要放冰箱
Lucia: Does this vegetable need to go in the fridge?
Lucia: 这个今天晚上要用吗
Lucia: Are we using this tonight?
Alice: 不用
Alice: No.
露丝：那就放冰箱
Lucia: Then just put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 这可乐不适合放在这里了已经
Tasha: This cola shouldn't be placed here anymore.
Lucia: 这个我觉得这个袋子里剩下的东西
Lucia: I think the stuff left in this bag
Lucia: 应该都是放常温就行
Lucia: should just be kept at room temperature.
Lucia: 大家可以检查一下
Lucia: Everyone can check it out.
Tasha: 午餐肉放进去吧
Tasha: Let's put the luncheon meat in.
Jake: OK了我把这个倒掉
Jake: Okay, I'll pour this out.
Jake: 呃弄一个小垃圾袋吧
Jake: Uh, let's get a small trash bag.
Alice: 我换个鞋
Alice: I'll change my shoes.
Tasha: 那就拿这个不就行了吗
Tasha: Why not just use this one?
Jake: 这个太大了
Jake: This one's too big.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 这是这些也是火锅的
Tasha: These are for the hotpot too.
Lucia: 刚那个火锅底料在哪放着呢
Lucia: Where did we put the hotpot base just now?
Tasha: 这呢这这都是调味料
Tasha: Here, these are all seasonings.
Tasha: 这个袋子里的
Tasha: In this bag.
Lucia: 那就把这个
Lucia: Then let's put this
Alice:火锅底料在这呢
Alice: The hotpot base is here.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那要不把那个火锅底料也放到这里面
Lucia: Then let's put the hotpot base in here too.
Lucia: 然后这个
Lucia: And then this
Lucia: 这个红薯跟这些东西放一起
Lucia: Put the sweet potatoes together with these.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Eh?
Lucia: 为什么我买了两袋红薯
Lucia: Why did I buy two bags of sweet potatoes?
Tasha: 一不一样的
Tasha: They're different.
Alice: 不样的品种
Alice: Different varieties.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 这个鸡蛋放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put these eggs?
Tasha: 哎呦这个厨房好小呀
Tasha: Oh, this kitchen is so small.
Alice: 这这这置物架
Alice: This, this, this shelf.
Alice: 置物架
Alice: The shelf.
Tasha: 可是感觉哎
Tasha: But it feels like, eh...
Tasha: 方罩不太好拿
Tasha: It's not easy to reach.
Alice: 没事用的时候再拿出来
Alice: It's okay, just take it out when you need it.
Lucia: 这个要不就放这个里面
Lucia: How about we put this in here?
Lucia: 跟这些放一起
Lucia: With these.
Lucia: 然后装就暂时放这袋子里
Lucia: And then we can temporarily store it in this bag.
Lucia: 那个咖啡放这里面
Lucia: Put the coffee in here too.
Alice: 也放里面吧
Alice: Put it in here as well.
Alice: 这个没地安置
Alice: There's no place for this.
Alice: 他也放那吧
Alice: Just put it there.
Alice: 感觉他在哪里都不好看
Alice: I feel like it doesn't look good anywhere.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 就放这了
Jake: Just put it here.
Jake: 啊这两个
Jake: Ah, these two.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do you still want them?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Just put it here.
Tasha: 就放这
Tasha: Just put it here.
Lucia: 要一下 要一下也行
Lucia: We can take it, that's fine too.
Lucia: 这个会坏的这么快吗
Lucia: Will this spoil so quickly?
Alice: 昨天到现在都快24小时
Alice: It's been almost 24 hours since yesterday.
Alice:赶紧给它喝了不得了
Alice: Hurry up and drink it already.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Lucia: 咱今天晚上把它喝了要不
Lucia: How about we finish it tonight?
Tasha: 嗯，不要再放了
Tasha: Yeah, let's not leave it anymore.
Jake:带劲了
Jake: Let's do it.
Jake: 这玻璃隔音确实一般
Jake: This glass soundproofing is really average.
Jake: 听的还挺哈哈哈
Jake: I can still hear pretty clearly, haha.
Jake: 丢掉了
Jake: Thrown away.
Katrina:  你那个蛋挞皮跟芋泥是怎么弄的芋圆
Katrina: How did you make the tart crust and the taro balls?
Alice:荔浦芋头就行
Alice: Just use Lipu taro.
Katrina:  买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Alice:没有没有
Alice: No, no.
Tasha: 我挑好了
Tasha: I picked it out.
Katrina:  外送还是快递的
Katrina: Delivery or courier?
Tasha: 呃快递的
Tasha: Uh, courier.
Katrina: 就是你买的是吧
Katrina: So you bought it, right?
Katrina:  蛋挞皮跟那个芋头
Katrina: The tart crust and that taro.
Tasha: 挑好了还没下单呢
Tasha: I picked it out but haven't ordered it yet.
Katrina:  哦我给你寄一下
Katrina: Oh, I'll send it to you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 还有展架
Tasha: And the display stand.
Jake: 帮我干一下
Jake: Help me with this.
Alice: 干一下
Alice: Help with this.
Jake:就帮我这个
Jake: Just help me with this.
Tasha: 扒拉一下
Tasha: Give it a push.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake: 留在这
Jake: Stay here
Alice:想换个鞋
Alice: I want to change my shoes
Jake: 看看还有什么垃圾我一起扔出去
Jake: Let's see if there's any other trash we can throw out together
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one
Lucia: 这个是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Jake: 这个得是垃圾
Jake: This must be trash
Tasha: 对哦这个时候应该派出我们的
Tasha: Oh right, at this time we should send out our...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake:哦吼吼
Jake: Oh ho ho
Lucia: 吼有道理
Lucia: Makes sense
Tasha: 有道呵呵
Tasha: Yeah, makes sense, haha
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah yeah yeah
Lucia: 先看一下一会把就是该扔的都扔了
Lucia: Let's check and throw out everything we need to
Lucia: 然后再擦
Lucia: Then clean
Katrina:  还好没有买时钟
Katrina: Good thing we didn't buy a clock
Lucia: 还有没有啥要扔的
Lucia: Is there anything else to throw away?
Tasha: 没有买什么
Tasha: We didn't buy what?
Katrina: 时钟
Katrina: A clock
Alice: 有那个厨房
Alice: There's that kitchen...
Jake:快递
Jake: Delivery
Katrina:  快递就是一个普通的钟就行了
Katrina: The delivery is just a regular clock
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yeah, right
Lucia: 你透气啊
Lucia: You need to breathe
Katrina:  要挂的吗
Katrina: Do we need to hang it?
Katrina:  还是白的
Katrina: And it's white
Jake: 呃我来买这个就好
Jake: Uh, I'll buy this one
Tasha: 为什么要买时钟
Tasha: Why do we need a clock?
Katrina:  我不知道他这些啊
Katrina: I don't know about these things
Jake: 因为要计时
Jake: Because we need to time things
Jake: 各位 3个小时那个呃
Jake: Everyone, the 3-hour...
Tasha: 盒子
Tasha: Box
Tasha: 啥盒子就是甜品的不同的盒子
Tasha: What box? Just different boxes for desserts
Tasha: 对甜品盒
Tasha: Yeah, dessert boxes
Tasha: 行就这么多应该就这行
Tasha: Alright, that's it, this should be enough
Jake:好妙
Jake: Brilliant
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 其他的应该收拾的差不多
Lucia: Everything else should be almost done
Jake:扔完了是吧
Jake: We're done throwing out the trash, right?
Jake: 那我出去扔掉
Jake: Then I'll go out and throw it away.
Lucia: 这俩袋子
Lucia: These two bags
Lucia: 可以留着就这两天在倒垃圾用
Lucia: Can be kept for taking out the trash in the next few days.
Jake: 那个是什么
Jake: What is that?
Lucia: 薇传
Lucia: It's cling film.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film
Lucia: 你说这个吗
Lucia: You mean this?
Lucia: 呃这个
Lucia: Uh, this
Alice: 那个鲜花的
Alice: The flower nutrient
Tasha: 营养剂
Tasha: Nutrient solution
Lucia: 鲜花的营养液
Lucia: Flower nutrient solution
Alice:可以把它扔了啊
Alice: You can throw it away.
Alice: 不用也行
Alice: It's okay not to use it.
Katrina:  倒进去要不要
Katrina: Should we pour it in?
Jake: 啊不用了
Jake: Ah, no need.
Lucia: 这个需要用吗
Lucia: Do we need to use this?
Lucia: 不用就可以不用哦
Lucia: If not, we don't have to use it.
Tasha:哦 用的话花会活的更久
Tasha: Oh, using it will make the flowers last longer.
Katrina:  那往里面倒一点我
Katrina: Then pour a little in.
Katrina:  来倒哈哈
Katrina: Let me pour it, haha.
Jake: 那就不用了
Jake: Then there's no need.
Lucia: 那就随便了
Lucia: Then it's up to you.
Lucia: 我来倒太懂了
Lucia: I'll pour it, I got it.
Jake: 打了起来
Jake: It's getting intense.
Lucia: 扎马斯
Lucia: Zamasu
Jake:扎马炮
Jake: Zama punch
Katrina:  打起来打起来
Katrina: Fight, fight!
Jake: 喜欢打起来
Jake: Loves to fight.
Jake: 喜欢
Jake: Loves it.
Jake: 好数据
Jake: Good data.
Katrina: 什么时候打起来他就高兴了
Katrina: He gets happy whenever there's a fight.
Katrina:  有素材了
Katrina: Got some material now.
Lucia: 增加一些动态的打架效果是吧
Lucia: Adding some dynamic fighting effects, right?
Katrina:  他那个点外卖了吗
Katrina: Did he order takeout?
Lucia: 哎这是哦
Lucia: Oh, that's right.
Lucia: 我还
Lucia: I still...
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: It's this one.
Lucia: 这他这他今天一天开成这样的吗
Lucia: Did he keep it like this all day?
Katrina:  这个东西他会长成这个
Katrina: This thing will grow like this.
Lucia: 因为我记得拿出来的时候他还是
Lucia: Because I remember when it was taken out, it was still...
Lucia: 都还是花苞
Lucia: They're still buds.
Katrina:  对对对他芍药是送的是花球
Katrina: Yes, yes, he sent peonies as flower balls.
Alice: 嗯然后那个量就是他不能不能太浓
Alice: Hmm, and the amount, it can't be too concentrated.
Katrina:  嗯这个芍药容易分到6个里面
Katrina: Hmm, it's easy to split these peonies into six.
Lucia: 太浓了是容易给他扎  虫吗
Lucia: If it's too concentrated, will it attract bugs?
Alice:烧死
Alice: Burn to death.
Alice:哦OK
Alice: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 我之前养一个水蚤
Lucia: I once kept a water flea.
Lucia: 是就是如果加多了会容易长虫
Lucia: If you add too much, it easily attracts bugs.
Lucia: 就是营养过剩然后就
Lucia: It's like overfeeding, and then...
Katrina:  稍等一下
Katrina: Hold on a second.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Katrina:  他们点外卖了吗
Katrina: Did they order takeout?
Lucia: 好像还没有
Lucia: Seems like they haven't yet.
Alice: 还没点
Alice: Not yet.
Alice:我们今天这是录的第几段啊
Alice: How many segments have we recorded today?
Alice: 第二段吧
Alice: This should be the second segment, right?
Lucia: 对应该还属于第二段
Lucia: Yes, it should still be the second segment.
Alice: 是不是还有一段
Alice: Do we have another segment to go?
Lucia: 可能还有一个两个小时
Lucia: Maybe another one or two hours.
Katrina:  但是晚上好像没说啥活动哎
Katrina: But there doesn't seem to be any activities tonight.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice: 明天啥活动
Alice: What activities are there tomorrow?
Alice: 那怎么有个咖啡啊
Alice: Why is there a coffee?
Lucia: 刚买的吧
Lucia: Probably just bought it.
Alice: 给他归置到哪
Alice: Where should we put it?
Alice: 火锅底料那
Alice: With the hotpot base.
Alice: 那不算可以
Alice: That doesn't really count.
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 因为有一个速溶咖啡在火锅底料里
Lucia: Because there's an instant coffee in the hotpot base.
Alice: 这个好看的放冰箱里
Alice: The nice-looking ones go in the fridge.
Alice: 虽然它不用放冰箱
Alice: Even though it doesn't need to be refrigerated,
Alice: 但我就想把它放冰箱
Alice: I just want to put it in the fridge.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 这里面还放了几只
Lucia: There are a few more in here.
Katrina:  哎 12341234是6个
Katrina: Oh, 1234, 1234, that's six.
Katrina:  6个用一包应该没事吧
Katrina: Six should be okay with one packet, right?
Alice: 上面应该有
Alice: It should say on it.
Alice: 那个浓度多少升
Alice: The concentration per liter.
Alice: 配比的那个
Alice: The ratio part.
Katrina:  0点三liters什么意思
Katrina: What does 0.3 liters mean?
Katrina:  呃Rage 0.3升
Katrina: Uh, Rage 0.3 liters.
Jake:l升
Jake: 1 liter.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 就是300毫升哎
Lucia: It's 300 milliliters.
Lucia: 我觉得咱这个应该稀释
Lucia: I think we should dilute this.
Katrina:  每一包用0.3升的水
Katrina: Use 0.3 liters of water for each pack.
Katrina:  这都有3升了
Katrina: That's 3 liters in total.
Lucia: 那那肯定够了
Lucia: Then that should be enough.
Alice: 0.3升对这么浓的吗
Alice: 0.3 liters for something this concentrated?
Alice: 他就给了一包哎对哎
Alice: He only gave one pack, right?
Jake: 试一试新买的湿巾纸
Jake: Let's try the new wet wipes we bought.
Jake: 嗯这300毫80毫升0.38
Jake: Hmm, this is 300 milliliters, 80 milliliters, 0.38.
Alice: 这么多花
Alice: So many flowers.
Alice: 他才给了一包
Alice: He only gave one pack.
Katrina:  这也不知道谁的水
Katrina: Whose water is this?
Katrina:  用来浇花吧哎
Katrina: Let's use it to water the flowers.
Alice: 我刚打开的哦
Alice: I just opened it, oh.
Alice: 哈哈哈我以为是我早上的呢
Alice: Haha, I thought it was from this morning.
Jake: 其实是知道的
Jake: Actually, I knew.
Katrina:  哈哈哈想制造冲突是吧哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, trying to create conflict, huh? Haha.
Jake: 背景音乐来个音效
Jake: Let's add some background music.
Lucia: 嘿Siri
Lucia: Hey Siri.
Lucia: 啊让Siri放首歌
Lucia: Ah, let's ask Siri to play a song.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 啊不用洗洁精吗
Alice: Ah, don't we need dish soap?
Jake: 用用用只是试一下这个
Jake: Yes, yes, we're just trying this out.
Lucia: 试一下这个厨房纸
Lucia: Let's try this kitchen paper.
Jake: 对对给他点面子
Jake: Yeah, let's give it a shot.
Jake: 买都买了
Jake: We bought it anyway.
Jake: 用他一下
Jake: Let's use it.
Alice: 买都买
Alice: We bought it.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Lucia: 等到咱们吃火锅的时候他应该很有用
Lucia: It should be useful when we have hotpot.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 外卖咱还没点了
Jake: We haven't ordered takeout yet.
Katrina:  呃点吧现在有点饿
Katrina: Uh, let's order now, I'm a bit hungry.
Jake: 咱午饭没多久但是可以饿
Jake: We just had lunch not too long ago, but being hungry is possible.
Katrina:  我感觉我属于那种饱的快
Katrina: I feel like I get full quickly.
Katrina:  饿的也快那种
Katrina: And get hungry quickly too.
Katrina:  少吃多餐
Katrina: Eat less, but more frequently.
Lucia: 这是什么呀
Lucia: What is this?
Alice: 沙球
Alice: Sand ball.
Lucia: 是这样玩的吗
Lucia: Is this how you play it?
Jake: 呃配乐的
Jake: Uh, it's for music.
Katrina:  这样这样这样这样
Katrina: Like this, like this, like this.
Jake: 这是修硕的
Jake: This belongs to Shure.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Jake: 对小礼品
Jake: It's a small gift.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 这个好像还没有互相送
Jake: It seems we haven't exchanged gifts yet.
Katrina:  没有交换礼物这个环节
Katrina: No gift exchange segment.
Jake: 有
Jake: There is.
Katrina: 啊对啊对
Katrina: Oh right, right.
Jake: 我说还没有到
Jake: I mean, it hasn't happened yet.
Alice: 对对我以为要放在后边呢
Alice: Right, I thought it would be later.
Jake: 嗯对这个每天都整点小游戏嘛
Jake: Yeah, we have a small game every day.
Alice: 把那个叶子给它捞出来
Alice: Scoop out those leaves.
Alice: 要不然它会烂
Alice: Otherwise, they'll rot.
Katrina:  哦我感觉我不太懂这边
Katrina: Oh, I feel like I don't quite understand this.
Jake: 就是各位破冰破的太快了
Jake: You guys broke the ice too quickly.
Jake: 一下就破了
Jake: It broke all at once.
Jake: 哈哈哈一下就破
Jake: Hahaha, it broke all at once.
Jake: 哈哈哈感觉不用
Jake: Hahaha, feels like we don't need...
Lucia: 迅速的熟识了起来
Lucia: Quickly got to know each other.
Jake: 对感觉不用什么礼物
Jake: Yeah, feels like we don't need any gifts.
Lucia: 芍药真的好好看哦
Lucia: Peonies are really beautiful.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  你看我的压花
Katrina: Look at my pressed flower.
Jake: 哇这咖啡这么好
Jake: Wow, this coffee is so good.
Jake: 你们谁先选
Jake: Who wants to pick first?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:就是你了
Jake: It's you.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What for?
Jake: 选一家
Jake: Pick a shop.
Lucia: 选个吃的吧
Lucia: Pick something to eat.
Tasha: 就这几家选吗
Tasha: Just these few shops to choose from?
Jake: 应该不止几家
Jake: There should be more than a few.
Alice: 嗯嗯这个是不是也快到时间了
Alice: Hmm, is this one about to be done too?
Alice: 慢
Alice: Slow down.
Jake: 呃你可以看一下这个还有多少story
Jake: Uh, can you check how many stories are left?
Jake: 120G是三个小时啊
Jake: 120G is three hours.
Jake: 110G三个小时
Jake: 110G is three hours.
Tasha: 啥呀
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade dish.
Alice:死亡菜
Alice: Death dish.
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade dish.
Alice: 哦私房菜
Alice: Oh, homemade dish.
Jake: 酸菜炖啊
Jake: Sauerkraut stew.
Tasha: 我没有说要吃这个菜啊
Tasha: I didn't say I wanted to eat this dish.
Jake: 我知道我知道OK
Jake: I know, I know, okay.
Jake: 红烧土豆   红烧土豆
Jake: Braised potatoes, braised potatoes.
Jake: 哈哈他叫土豆侠子你知道吗
Jake: Haha, he's called Potato Knight, you know?
Alice: 土豆侠子
Alice: Potato Knight.
Lucia: 所以会吃土豆
Lucia: So he eats potatoes.
Jake: 上来给我看一堆土豆
Jake: He brought me a bunch of potatoes.
Alice: 他喜欢土豆
Alice: He likes potatoes.
Jake: 喜欢吃土豆
Jake: Likes eating potatoes.
Tasha: 是的嗯只要花298就可以加入我的土门
Tasha: Yes, for just 298, you can join my potato club.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是因为这个所以叫土豆侠子吗
Lucia: But is that why he's called Potato Knight?
Lucia: 啊就是是因为
Lucia: Ah, so it's because...
Lucia: 你是因为喜欢吃土豆
Lucia: You like eating potatoes...
Lucia: 所以叫土豆侠子的吗
Lucia: So you're called Potato Knight?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 怎么觉得听起来有点像
Lucia: Why does it sound like...
Lucia: 一个编出来的理由
Lucia: A made-up reason?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 门店热销土豆红烧肉盖饭就这个吧
Jake: The store's best-selling braised pork with potatoes, let's get that.
Tasha: 啊每个人吃自己的饭是吗
Tasha: Ah, everyone eats their own meal, right?
Tasha: 哦也可以哦
Tasha: Oh, that works too.
Jake: 你说点这种大菜是吧
Jake: You mean order big dishes, right?
Tasha: 哦我以为是点大菜
Tasha: Oh, I thought we were ordering big dishes.
Jake: 哦那也行啊点大菜
Jake: Oh, that's fine too, let's order big dishes.
Jake: 那每人点一个吧
Jake: Then each person orders one.
Tasha: 每人点一个
Tasha: Each person orders one.
Tasha: 嗯四个女生
Tasha: Hmm, four girls.
Tasha: 我感觉吃两到三个菜就差不多了
Tasha: I feel like two to three dishes should be enough.
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 对嗯差不多
Lucia: Yeah, pretty much.
Jake: 那你先点一个
Jake: Then you order one first.
Jake: 你先点个土豆吧
Jake: You order a potato dish first.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Jake:啊你找一个土豆店不点土豆
Jake: Ah, you go to a potato shop and don't order potatoes?
Lucia: 点一个里面带土豆的菜
Lucia: Order a dish with potatoes in it.
Katrina:  点那种什么肉蟹煲
Katrina: Order that crab pot thing.
Katrina:  什么什么煲里面很多土豆
Katrina: The one with lots of potatoes in it.
Katrina:  嗯就是他根本就没有那么多肉
Katrina: Yeah, it doesn't actually have that much meat.
Tasha: 哇感觉好好吃
Tasha: Wow, it sounds so good.
Alice: 哪个
Alice: Which one?
Jake:想象出来的肉蟹煲
Jake: The imaginary crab pot.
Jake: 土豆包
Jake: Potato pot.
Alice:吓我一跳
Alice: You scared me!
Tasha: 记得备注一下不要香菜
Tasha: Remember to note, no cilantro.
Alice:你说啥呀
Alice: What did you say?
Tasha: 不要啥菜啊
Tasha: No what?
Alice: 你点的啥
Alice: What did you order?
Alice: 我点了个水煮肉
Alice: I ordered boiled pork.
Alice: 麻辣水煮肉猪肉
Alice: Spicy boiled pork, pork.
Tasha: 你不吃猪肉吗
Tasha: You don't eat pork?
Alice: 你认识这个字吗
Alice: Do you recognize this word?
Tasha: 干靠大牙
Tasha: Something to do with teeth.
Tasha: 哈哈喂鹅吗
Tasha: Haha, feeding geese?
Katrina:  哇康乃馨花瓣居然要分开吗
Katrina: Wow, do you really have to separate the carnation petals?
Tasha: 这个好用吗
Tasha: Does this work well?
Tasha: 这个厨房湿巾
Tasha: This kitchen wipe.
Tasha: 没有没有我不是说要点这个
Tasha: No, no, I didn't mean to order this.
Lucia: 我就是刚
Lucia: I just...
Tasha: 我说这个好用吗
Tasha: I mean, does this work well?
Lucia: 好像还不错的样子
Lucia: It seems pretty good.
Tasha: 哇感觉它好便宜啊面吗
Tasha: Wow, it feels so cheap.
Lucia: 哎它多少钱
Lucia: How much is it?
Tasha: 一包九块九
Tasha: 9.9 yuan for a pack.
Katrina:  九块九这
Katrina: 9.9 yuan?
Lucia: 还挺大包哎
Lucia: It's a pretty big pack.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 我感觉一片就可以把所有的碗都抹了
Tasha: I feel like one sheet can clean all the dishes.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对对对
Lucia: Haha, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 正确用法
Lucia: That's the right way to use it.
Katrina:  想想还有什么
Katrina: Think if there's anything else.
Lucia: 来看看菜吗姐妹
Lucia: Want to take a look at the dishes, sisters?
Katrina: 好的
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina:  哦点家常菜是吧
Katrina: Oh, you're ordering home-style dishes, right?
Alice: 点大餐好像说的是无所谓吧
Alice: Ordering a feast, it doesn't really matter, right?
Katrina:  咪现在点了什么
Katrina: What did Mi order now?
Alice: 嗯麻辣水煮肉
Alice: Hmm, spicy boiled meat.
Katrina:  我想吃孜然牛肉
Katrina: I want cumin beef.
Tasha: 冰箱居然没有关
Tasha: The fridge isn't closed.
Alice:关了呀
Alice: I closed it.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No, you didn't.
Alice:没关严是吧
Alice: It’s not closed tight, right?
Katrina:  啊啊看看你们这装满
Katrina: Ah, look, you guys packed it full.
Katrina:  这上面还有好大的位置哦
Katrina: There's still a lot of space up here.
Katrina:  牛奶在这里
Katrina: The milk is here.
Katrina:  上面全是酒哦
Katrina: And it's all alcohol up here.
Katrina:  啊养乐多在这
Katrina: Ah, the Yakult is here.
Katrina:  好爽这能不能成为我的家
Katrina: So cozy, can this be my home?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 别哈哈哈
Lucia: Stop laughing.
Alice: 唤起你的回忆了
Alice: Triggered your memories?
Tasha: 你看我的眼睛
Tasha: Look at my eyes.
Tasha: 这里好好热呀
Tasha: It's really hot here.
Katrina:  嗯我也是
Katrina: Yeah, me too.
Katrina:  他工作久了
Katrina: He's been working for a long time.
Alice: 是这是这吗
Alice: Is this the one?
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This one, this one.
Lucia: 电池好像比较容易烫的样子
Lucia: The battery seems to get hot easily.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  今天我那一小辫
Katrina: Today, my little braid...
Alice:是你最爱的娃娃吗
Alice: Is it your favorite doll?
Lucia: 哈哈哈点一个不要备注
Lucia: Hahaha, order one without any notes.
Lucia: 不要雪块
Lucia: No ice cubes.
Lucia: 哈哈给店家干蒙了
Lucia: Haha, left the shopkeeper confused.
Katrina:  哇好温馨啊
Katrina: Wow, so cozy.
Tasha: 都是用钱堆出来的
Tasha: It's all built with money.
Lucia: 嗯刚才那个姐妹点的孜然牛肉就是
Lucia: Hmm, that cumin beef the sister ordered earlier...
Lucia: 已经基本上是我想要点的菜了
Lucia: Is basically what I wanted to order.
Lucia: 很重合
Lucia: Very similar.
Lucia: 干锅娃娃菜
Lucia: Dry pot baby cabbage
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 干锅什么
Tasha: Dry pot what?
Alice:娃娃菜
Alice: Baby cabbage
Alice: 要吗没有没有
Alice: Do you want it? No, no.
Lucia: 我是说你好像喜欢吃娃娃菜的样子
Lucia: I mean, you seem to like baby cabbage.
Alice: 我我一般还行
Alice: I-I usually think it's okay.
Lucia: 啊OK 因为你之前说你做那个
Lucia: Ah, okay. Because you mentioned you made that...
Alice:上汤娃娃菜
Alice: Baby cabbage in broth.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 你们晚上是propose的什么活动来着
Jake: What activities did you propose for tonight?
Tasha: propose了
Tasha: We proposed...
Jake: 你们是逛超市的时候
Jake: When you were shopping?
Jake: propose的两个什么
Jake: You proposed two things, right?
Jake: 要做菜做甜点
Jake: To cook and make dessert.
Jake: 做半个小时甜点
Jake: Make a dessert in half an hour.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 你为啥不点土豆啊
Alice: Why didn't you order potatoes?
Alice: 我给你点上吧
Alice: I'll order them for you.
Alice: 哈哈排骨土豆炖豆角
Alice: Haha, ribs with potatoes and green beans.
Alice: 还有啥土豆啊
Alice: What else with potatoes?
Alice: 给你找都
Alice: I'll find it for you.
Tasha: 都可以都可以
Tasha: Anything's fine, anything's fine.
Alice: 排骨土豆
Alice: Ribs and potatoes.
Tasha: 要不要吃回锅肉
Tasha: Do you want twice-cooked pork?
Alice: 那你不要你的土豆了
Alice: Then you don't want your potatoes?
Tasha: 可以不要
Tasha: I can do without.
Tasha: 哈哈回锅肉
Tasha: Haha, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 锅包肉锅包肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork, sweet and sour pork.
Tasha: 番茄牛腩
Tasha: Tomato beef brisket.
Jake: 白板担当
Jake: Whiteboard duty.
Tasha: 嗯都可以
Tasha: Hmm, anything's fine.
Alice: 这个或者
Alice: This one or...
Alice: 哎你刚说哪个
Alice: Hey, which one did you just say?
Tasha: 锅包肉回锅肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 哈哈要两种肉
Tasha: Haha, two kinds of pork.
Alice:麻辣的孜然的
Alice: Spicy cumin.
Alice: 这是酸辣的
Alice: This one is hot and sour.
Alice: 你更想吃哪个
Alice: Which one do you want to eat more?
Katrina:  是我们四个
Katrina: It's the four of us.
Katrina:  还带他一起吗
Katrina: Are we bringing him along too?
Katrina:  一起的是吧
Katrina: Together, right?
Lucia: 对我们一起四个菜
Lucia: Yes, the four of us together.
Katrina:  三荤一素三
Katrina: Three meat dishes and one vegetable.
Tasha: 哦有素菜吗
Tasha: Oh, is there a vegetable dish?
Tasha: 我们没有点过素菜
Tasha: We haven't ordered a vegetable dish.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 你俩想吃哪个你点两个啊
Alice: You two, pick the ones you want to eat and order two more.
Lucia: 或者或者或者番茄牛腩
Lucia: Or, or, or the tomato beef.
Lucia: 里面有番茄
Lucia: It has tomatoes in it.
Lucia: 哈哈是吧
Lucia: Haha, right?
Lucia: 姑且算是半个素菜
Lucia: Let's count it as half a vegetable dish.
Lucia: 那那素菜
Lucia: Then, then a vegetable dish.
Tasha: 素菜里面要一个手撕包菜
Tasha: For the vegetable dish, let's have shredded cabbage.
Tasha: 或者要一个酸辣土豆丝 哈哈
Tasha: Or we can have the spicy shredded potatoes. Haha.
Alice: 可以土豆在这等着呢啊
Alice: Sure, the potatoes are here waiting.
Tasha: 啊就这个吧
Tasha: Let's go with this one then.
Alice: 点吧
Alice: Order it.
Tasha: 然后刚刚那个菜
Tasha: And the dish we just mentioned.
Alice:稍薇有个荤菜在这
Alice: Tasha, there's a meat dish here.
Alice: 番茄牛腩
Alice: Tomato beef.
Alice: 还是啥可以
Alice: Or whatever, it's fine.
Tasha: 回锅肉会不会便宜点
Tasha: Wouldn't the twice-cooked pork be cheaper?
Alice: 这都差不多
Alice: They're all about the same.
Tasha: 40 68 58都可以
Tasha: 40, 68, 58, they're all fine.
Alice: 哪有62 你说哪有62
Alice: Where's the 62? What do you mean 62?
Tasha:  68 42
Tasha: 68, 42.
Alice:现在就开始煮汤
Alice: Let's start cooking the soup now.
Tasha: 还差个汤
Tasha: We're still missing a soup.
Tasha: 现在就开始煮吧
Tasha: Let's start cooking it now.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 今天晚上就喝吧
Alice: Let's drink it tonight.
Tasha: 是吧 是今天晚上开始做汤吗
Tasha: Right, we're making the soup tonight, right?
Tasha: 反正吃家常菜吗
Tasha: Anyway, it's just home-cooked food.
Jake: 可以啊你说等的时候做汤吗
Jake: Sure, are you saying to make the soup while we wait?
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Yeah, we can do that.
Jake: 他要送多久啊
Jake: How long will it take for delivery?
Jake: 40分钟
Jake: 40 minutes.
Alice:可能吧
Alice: Maybe.
Katrina:  送密封袋
Katrina: Send the sealed bag.
Tasha: 现在是7点半
Tasha: It's 7:30 now.
Katrina:  那我试验一下
Katrina: Let me test it out.
Tasha: 那我现在开始在做甜品的话
Tasha: If I start making desserts now,
Tasha: 8点半还能开会哦
Tasha: we can still have a meeting at 8:30.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  今天晚上开会吗
Katrina: Are we having a meeting tonight?
Alice: 点这个吧
Alice: Let's choose this.
Alice: 我不太想吃猪
Alice: I don't really want to eat pork.
Alice: 可以吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Tasha: 可以啊可以
Tasha: Yeah, sure.
Jake: 我自己要开会
Jake: I need to have a meeting myself.
Katrina:  我可能有点事
Katrina: I might have something to do.
Alice: 那我们开始做吧
Alice: Let's get started then.
Alice: 你让他点
Alice: Let him choose.
Katrina:  摘两片芍药花瓣
Katrina: Pick two peony petals.
Tasha: 神圣的交接仪
Tasha: The sacred handover ceremony.
Alice: 来吧我们开始吧
Alice: Come on, let's start.
Tasha: 好我们开始吧
Tasha: Okay, let's start.
Alice: 我们几个人做汤的话需要
Alice: If we are making soup for everyone, we'll need...
Tasha: 你需要一个配手
Tasha: You need an assistant.
Tasha: 我需要一个配手
Tasha: I need an assistant.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Alice:我不需要哦
Alice: I don't need one.
Alice: 我自己给自己打下手
Alice: I can handle it myself.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  好 需要我帮忙吗
Katrina: Alright, do you need my help?
Alice: 我们需要做多少量呢
Alice: How much do we need to make?
Tasha: 嗯嗯一人一碗的量就行
Tasha: Just enough for one bowl each.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:一人一碗是
Alice: One bowl each is...
Alice: 哎我不知道大家的饭量
Alice: I don't know how much everyone eats.
Alice: 嗯对汤就汤多
Alice: Well, for soup, just make more.
Lucia: 汤嘛
Lucia: Soup, right?
Alice:对 就汤多
Alice: Yeah, just make more soup.
Alice: 一点点也没什么对多少应该
Alice: A little extra won't hurt.
Lucia:汤一人一碗应该没多少关系
Lucia: One bowl of soup each should be fine.
Alice: 那我把我戒指取下来
Alice: Then I'll take off my ring.
Alice: 不行都放不掉
Alice: No, I can't let go of any of them.
Lucia: 需要我做什么呢
Lucia: What do you need me to do?
Lucia: 哈哈哈等待指派中
Lucia: Hahaha, waiting for instructions.
Tasha: 等一下
Tasha: Wait a second.
Jake:我问一下谢明珠来不来
Jake: Let me ask if Xie Mingzhu is coming.
Jake: 他有可能来
Jake: He might come.
Jake: 来的话就多加点
Jake: If he comes, we'll add a bit more.
Tasha: 哎米饭是不是没点
Tasha: Hey, did we order rice?
Tasha: 谁来谢冰珠
Tasha: Who's coming, Xie Bingzhu?
Tasha: 米饭掉了吗
Tasha: Did the rice drop?
Jake: 就是那个
Jake: It's that one.
Jake: 没有没点
Jake: No, we didn't order it.
Tasha: 为什么不点米饭
Tasha: Why didn't we order rice?
Jake: 因为我还没下单呢
Jake: Because I haven't placed the order yet.
Tasha: 哦那就行
Tasha: Oh, that's fine then.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice: 那我现在开始吧
Alice: Then I'll start now.
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scary.
Tasha: 好的你先开始
Tasha: Okay, you go ahead.
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scary.
Lucia: 我要不把
Lucia: Should I...
Tasha: 我就做简单的纸杯蛋糕吧
Tasha: I'll just make simple cupcakes.
Lucia: 做饭的话我要不要换个洞
Lucia: If I'm cooking, should I change the hole?
Lucia: 我能把它先摘下来一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it off for a bit?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 我换个衣服
Lucia: I'll change clothes.
Lucia: 这样好做一点
Lucia: It'll be easier.
Jake:唉，好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 不用关吧
Lucia: No need to close it, right?
Lucia: 我在这里放一下
Lucia: I'll just put it here.
Jake:你就放在这里，对对对
Jake: Just leave it here, yes, yes.
Lucia: 然后一会再下去
Lucia: Then I'll go down later.
Alice: 哎呀冻得梆梆硬
Alice: Oh, it's frozen solid.
Alice: 放上边吧
Alice: Put it on top.
Lucia: 我还以为我一直连着电线呢
Lucia: I thought it was always connected to the wire.
Lucia: 居然没有
Lucia: But it wasn't.
Jake: 好那就趁机充个电
Jake: Alright, then let's charge it while we can.
Lucia: 哎有道理
Lucia: Oh, good idea.
Lucia: 先把它连上
Lucia: Let's connect it first.
Alice: 怎么会把它放在这里面呢
Alice: How could you put it in here?
Alice: 我们是买了两个金针菇还是一个呀
Alice: Did we buy two packs of enoki mushrooms or just one?
Tasha: 一个好像
Tasha: Just one, I think.
Alice:一个
Alice: Just one.
Tasha: 一袋
Tasha: One bag.
Alice:一个吗
Alice: Just one?
Alice: 嗯是呢
Alice: Hmm, that's right.
Alice: 算了就这样吧
Alice: Never mind, let's just go with it.
Alice: 我怎么会把
Alice: How did I end up
Alice: 皮蛋放冷冻呢
Alice: putting the century eggs in the freezer?
小汾：花好香啊
Katrina: The flowers smell so nice.
Katrina:  到底是哪种花香
Katrina: What kind of flowers are they?
Alice: 开始吧
Alice: Let's get started.
Alice: 找一下盆
Alice: Let's find a basin.
Alice: 大刀
Alice: Big knife.
Alice: 锅在哪
Alice: Where's the pot?
Alice: 还要自己刷这个
Alice: I still need to scrub this myself.
Alice: 掉出来了掉出来了
Alice: It fell out, it fell out.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Alice: 就这个吧
Alice: Let's just use this.
Alice: 定个咣当的
Alice: Fix it with a bang.
Jake: 我去一把大菜刀
Jake: I'll get a big kitchen knife.
Jake: 这菜刀是不是不够
Jake: Is this kitchen knife not enough?
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Jake: 这菜刀是不是不够锋利
Jake: Is this kitchen knife not sharp enough?
Alice: 切个白菜无所谓
Alice: It's okay for chopping cabbage.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Alice: 我不太想让我的戒指沾水
Alice: I don't really want my ring to get wet.
Alice: 说实话我要给它去下来了
Alice: Honestly, I'm going to take it off.
Alice: 给你个神圣的职责照看他一下
Alice: I'm entrusting you with the sacred duty of watching over it.
Alice: 这锅几百年没刷了
Alice: This pot hasn't been scrubbed in ages.
Katrina:  这是干啥的
Katrina: What's this for?
Alice: 说实话这个锅没有很大
Alice: Honestly, this pot isn't very big.
Alice: 噔噔
Alice: Ta-da!
Alice: 菜板
Alice: Cutting board.
Alice: 这个也不能沾水
Alice: This can't get wet either.
Alice: 你帮我去掉一下
Alice: Can you help me take it off?
Jake: 你在切啥
Jake: What are you cutting?
Tasha: 加三次糖
Tasha: Add sugar three times.
Tasha: 我去不记得了
Tasha: Oh no, I can't remember.
Tasha: 呃不是不
Tasha: Uh, wait, no.
Tasha: 记得了具体的配方
Tasha: Remember the exact recipe.
Alice: 我先把你这个放一边了啊
Alice: I'll put yours aside for now.
Tasha: 抠这个这个行OK
Tasha: Just need to scrape this off. OK.
Tasha: 就这样
Tasha: Just like that.
Tasha: 然后烤箱温度记一下在
Tasha: And remember the oven temperature.
Alice: 哎呦我的天
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 真够危险
Alice: That was so dangerous.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Ta-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Tasha: can you help me
Tasha: Can you help me?
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: yes
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 呃我的无菌手套呢
Tasha: Uh, where are my sterile gloves?
Tasha: 被谁呢拿到哪里去了
Tasha: Who took them and where did they go?
Jake: 拿到什么
Jake: Took what?
Tasha: 哦在这里
Tasha: Oh, here they are.
Tasha: police and me take this
Tasha: Police and me take this.
Alice: 松花蛋在哪里
Alice: Where are the century eggs?
Jake: 松花蛋OK
Jake: Century eggs, OK.
Tasha: 松花蛋在这里在在
Tasha: The century eggs are here, right here.
Alice: 哦okay
Alice: Oh, okay.
Katrina: 有啥要要我帮忙的不
Katrina: Is there anything you need help with?
Katrina:  嗯i can我已经free了
Katrina: Hmm, I can help, I'm free now.
Katrina:  我看看我这压花
Katrina: Let me check my flower press.
Katrina:  这两天能压出什么东西
Katrina: See what I can press out in these two days.
Katrina:  哈哈哈先尝试一个
Katrina: Hahaha, let's try one first.
Jake: 压
Jake: Press.
Katrina:  我已经压了一个
Katrina: I already pressed one.
Jake: 你要在地上压还是最好有个桌子还是
Jake: Are you pressing on the ground? It’s better to have a table or something.
Katrina:  不是我那个板
Katrina: No, it's my board.
Katrina:  就是那个压花板
Katrina: The flower press board.
Katrina:  我已经放了几片花瓣进去了
Katrina: I already put a few petals inside.
Katrina:  不知道压出来什么效果
Katrina: Don't know what the result will be.
Katrina:  它不是也要两三天吗
Katrina: It takes two or three days, right?
Jake: 哦就是你你一直在地上压这个是不是
Jake: Oh, so you’ve been pressing this on the ground all the time?
Jake: 嗯伤腰啊
Jake: Hmm, it’s bad for your back.
Katrina:  没事年轻的
Katrina: It's okay, I'm young.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞 好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Tasha: 他在说你
Tasha: He's talking about you.
Jake: 对确实
Jake: Yeah, that's true.
Katrina:  今天下午坐地上插了花然后也压了
Katrina: This afternoon I sat on the ground arranging flowers and then I pressed them.
Jake: 哎你要哪个
Jake: Hey, which one do you want?
Tasha: 哦我有我其实
Tasha: Oh, I have one actually.
Tasha: 好吧那你不带也行
Tasha: Okay, you don't have to bring it.
Tasha: 我要这个你不用了吧
Tasha: I want this one, you don't need it, right?
Tasha: 哎呦哎好求助一下
Tasha: Oh, hey, I need some help.
Jake:我我能干这个
Jake: I can do this.
Jake: 哈哈来吧来吧
Jake: Haha, come on, come on.
Tasha: 我一开始是想让你也带一双的
Tasha: At first, I wanted you to bring a pair too.
Jake: 哦我以为你帮我
Jake: Oh, I thought you were helping me.
Jake: 你让我稍薇
Jake: You were asking me, Tasha.
Alice: 可以了thank you
Alice: It's fine, thank you.
Alice: 你可真难出来呀兄弟
Alice: You're really hard to get out, buddy.
Tasha: 哎那个
Tasha: Hey, that...
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Tasha: 我刚刚的那个大的那个盆呢
Tasha: Where's that big pot I had earlier?
Alice:盆
Alice: Pot.
Tasha: 大的那个盆
Tasha: The big pot.
Alice: 我给你搁那了
Alice: I put it over there for you.
Alice: 是那个吧
Alice: Is it that one?
Tasha: 哦我刀呢
Tasha: Oh, where's my knife?
Alice: 没洗呢
Alice: It hasn't been washed yet.
Tasha: 天呐这
Tasha: Oh my god, this...
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's up?
Tasha: 餐巾纸
Tasha: Napkin.
Jake: 有得等一下我先
Jake: You have to wait a bit, let me...
Alice: 比较大呀
Alice: It's quite big.
Alice: 太小
Alice: Too small.
Alice: 留着够我们几个人吃吗
Alice: Will it be enough for us to eat?
Alice: 够了够吗
Alice: Is it enough?
Tasha: 够了吧
Tasha: It should be enough.
Alice:要不把这半也切进去吧
Alice: Why don't we cut this half in too?
Tasha: 嗯行反正也不会做第二次了也许
Tasha: Hmm, okay, we probably won't make this again anyway.
Alice: 因为还有一块午餐肉
Alice: Because there's still a piece of lunch meat.
Tasha: 完了完了啊
Tasha: Done, done.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Alice: 炒鸡蛋吧没关系的
Alice: Scramble eggs, it's okay.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 没关系的宝贝
Alice: It's okay, baby.
Alice: 没关系没关系这个蛋就炒鸡蛋吧
Alice: It's alright, it's alright, just make scrambled eggs with this egg.
Tasha: 你这个里面需要蛋花吗
Tasha: Do you need egg drop in this?
Alice: 那倒不需要
Alice: No, we don't need that.
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Alice: 这是个问题
Alice: That's a problem.
Alice: 摆烂了是吧
Alice: Are you giving up?
Tasha: 想摆烂受不了了
Tasha: I feel like giving up, can't take it anymore.
Tasha: 失败了
Tasha: It's a failure.
Alice: 你喜欢吃午餐肉吗
Alice: Do you like eating luncheon meat?
Tasha: 还好
Tasha: It's okay.
Lucia: 还好是怎么办怎么办
Lucia: What do you mean "okay"? What should we do?
Tasha: 那我就放到这个里面了
Tasha: Then I'll just put it in here.
Alice: 啊啊啊
Alice: Ah, ah, ah!
Alice: 你要干嘛
Alice: What are you doing?
Tasha: 放进去
Tasha: Putting it in.
Alice: 你放这里面干嘛
Alice: Why are you putting it in there?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Alice: 天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 用不了上崩溃了
Tasha: I can't handle this, I'm breaking down.
Alice: 大白了
Alice: It's all messed up.
Alice: 这个午餐肉有点略薇的多了
Alice: This luncheon meat is a bit too much.
Alice: 不过没关系
Alice: But it's okay.
Alice: give me一个碗呵
Alice: Give me a bowl, please.
Jake: 呵
Jake: Sure.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 有水吗
Tasha: Is there water?
Alice: 没有人在吗
Alice: Is anyone here?
Alice: 我想让人帮我温点水算了一会
Alice: I wanted someone to warm up some water for me, forget it.
Katrina:  来吧我帮你吧
Katrina: I'll help you with that.
Alice: 哦我需要一点热水
Alice: Oh, I need some hot water.
Alice: 就是那个
Alice: Just a bit.
Katrina:  就帮你烧一壶开水
Katrina: I'll boil a kettle for you.
Alice: 对比较多的
Alice: Yeah, a little more.
Tasha: 你来帮我吗
Tasha: Will you help me?
Alice: 呃两升左右
Alice: Uh, around two liters.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Katrina: 这是多少
Katrina: How much is that?
Tasha: 这因为我现在遇到了一个难题
Tasha: Because I'm facing a problem right now.
Alice: 没关系多了也没事
Alice: It's okay, even if it's too much.
Lucia: 让我来
Lucia: Let me do it.
Katrina: 这应该没有两升
Katrina: This shouldn't be two liters.
Lucia: 我要上去换个衣服
Lucia: I'm going upstairs to change clothes.
Alice: 够也行就是跟那个裙子袖子很长
Alice: It's fine, but the sleeves on that dress are really long.
Lucia: 感觉做饭不方便
Lucia: It feels inconvenient for cooking.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 做甜品的话最重要的就是无油无水
Tasha: When making desserts, the most important thing is no oil and no water.
Tasha: 所以所有的盆都要把擦干
Tasha: So you have to dry all the bowls.
Lucia: 啊 OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Tasha: 擦的一滴水都没有
Tasha: They need to be completely dry.
Lucia: 啊  好的 没问题
Lucia: Ah, got it, no problem.
Katrina:  这是做什么汤来着
Katrina: What soup is this for?
Tasha: 不然会导致打发不出来
Tasha: Otherwise, it won't whip properly.
Lucia: 呃那我也要带一个这种一次性手套吗
Lucia: Do I need to wear these disposable gloves too?
Tasha: 可以不带
Tasha: You don't have to.
Tasha: 对不用带
Tasha: Yeah, no need.
Lucia: 哦行那我先去把手洗一下再
Lucia: Oh, okay, then I'll just wash my hands first.
Tasha: 呃你洗了手之后要把手擦干
Tasha: Uh, after you wash your hands, you need to dry them.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 因为刚换了个衣服害怕把手弄脏了
Lucia: I just changed clothes, so I'm worried about getting my hands dirty.
Alice: 外国人会见过这种蛋吗
Alice: Do foreigners know this kind of egg?
Alice: 他们是不是觉得这种蛋是一种意外的
Alice: Do they think this kind of egg is weird?
Lucia: 我这个还亮着 所以还在录吧
Lucia: Mine is still on, so it's still recording, right?
Alice: 异类的东西
Alice: Like some kind of oddity.
Katrina:  都会觉得这发霉了
Katrina: They probably think it's moldy.
Alice: 这其实是一种很好吃的蛋
Alice: It's actually a really tasty egg.
Alice: 屏幕前的朋友们
Alice: Friends watching the screen.
Alice: 如果你们有机会来中国的话
Alice: If you get a chance to come to China.
小汾：呵呵 外国朋友们
Katrina: Haha, foreign friends.
Alice: 我希望你们
Alice: I hope you.
Alice: 可以
Alice: Can.
Katrina:  没有水位线
Katrina: There's no waterline.
Alice: 希望不出一个比较好看的蛋
Alice: I hope it turns out to be a good-looking egg.
Alice: 哎不错
Alice: Oh, not bad.
Alice: this is a good蛋
Alice: This is a good egg.
Alice: good egg哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Good egg, hahaha.
Alice: 哎呀哎呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 对把这个盘擦一下哦
Tasha: Yes, wipe this plate.
Tasha: 已经放置了
Tasha: It's already set.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 不不我要把手先擦一下
Lucia: No, no, I need to dry my hands first.
Katrina:  对打鸡蛋吗
Katrina: So, should we beat the eggs?
Tasha: 呃先把盆擦一下
Tasha: Uh, first wipe the bowl.
Tasha: 然后再打鸡蛋
Tasha: Then beat the eggs.
Tasha: 稍等把鸡蛋给他喝
Tasha: Wait a sec, let him drink the egg.
Tasha: 对就是我碰无菌的东西
Tasha: Right, I handle the sterile stuff.
Tasha: 你碰有菌的东西
Tasha: You handle the non-sterile stuff.
Tasha: 这样子我们就可以保证食材的干净
Tasha: This way, we can ensure the ingredients are clean.
Katrina:  嘿嘿非常的专业
Katrina: Hehe, very professional.
Lucia: 哎这个桶又恢复正常了
Lucia: Hey, this bucket is back to normal.
Lucia: 啊我真服了
Lucia: Ah, I'm really impressed.
Lucia: 我这头发
Lucia: My hair...
Alice: 两个四个可能不太够
Alice: Two or four might not be enough.
Alice: 等一下两个
Alice: Wait a sec, two more.
Alice: 可能需要
Alice: We might need to...
Alice: 回温一下下
Alice: Let it warm up a bit.
Alice: 因为这个不小心放进了冷冻
Alice: Because it accidentally got put in the freezer.
Alice: 冷冻的切不动
Alice: It's too hard to cut when frozen.
Alice: 哎呦妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 所以让他解冻好
Alice: So let it thaw properly.
Alice: 自己带解说的
Alice: With its own explanation.
Tasha: 自带解说
Tasha: With its own explanation.
Tasha: 那我也洗个碗呗
Tasha: I'll wash a dish too.
Lucia: 这个盆是他们民宿这的吗
Lucia: Is this bowl from their B&B?
Tasha: 我买的
Tasha: I bought it.
Lucia: 哦哦我说怎么会有这么
Lucia: Oh, I was wondering why there's such...
Tasha:先进的碗
Tasha: An advanced bowl.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: OK可以了吗
Tasha: OK, is it ready?
Tasha: 这个也擦一下嗯 行
Tasha: Wipe this too, hmm, okay.
Katrina:  哇有花的房间就是不一样
Katrina: Wow, a room with flowers is just different.
Katrina:  拍出来可好看了
Katrina: It looks so good in photos.
Tasha: 可以再拿一张纸
Tasha: Can you get another piece of paper?
Alice: 我希望他不要糖心
Alice: I hope it's not runny.
Alice: 他一糖心他就会
Alice: If it's runny, it will...
Katrina:  纸杯蛋糕
Katrina: Cupcakes.
Alice:到哪都是
Alice: Everywhere.
Katrina:  好好看呀好爽啊
Katrina: Looks so good, so satisfying.
Lucia: 光把蛋黄捞出来
Lucia: Just scoop out the yolk.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Uh-huh, right.
Tasha: 你能打下下一个吗
Tasha: Can you beat the next one?
Tasha: 我这手有点黏糊了
Tasha: My hands are a bit sticky.
Lucia: 没问题
Lucia: No problem.
Tasha: 一定要打的很低
Tasha: You have to beat it really low.
Tasha: 他就不会散开
Tasha: Then it won't spread out.
Lucia: 打的很低
Lucia: Beat it really low.
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh no.
Tasha: 啊啊坏了
Tasha: Oh no, it's ruined.
Tasha: 呃重做了
Tasha: We'll have to redo it.
Tasha: 要重新打蛋了
Tasha: We need to beat the eggs again.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: 我们今天是不是得吃炒鸡蛋了宝
Alice: Are we having scrambled eggs today, babe?
Tasha: 嗯他不
Tasha: Hmm, it won't...
Tasha: 他要打的很低才行啊
Tasha: It has to be beaten really low.
Lucia: 要多我我觉得这样
Lucia: I think we need more...
Lucia: 因为我感觉再往下
Lucia: Because I feel like if we go lower...
Lucia: 好像蛋壳会碰到这个
Lucia: The eggshell might touch this.
Lucia: 蛋清嗯嗯
Lucia: The egg white, yeah.
Tasha: 流出来就失败了哦
Tasha: If it flows out, it's a failure.
Lucia: 啊这为什么
Lucia: Why is that?
Katrina:  为什么嗯
Katrina: Why, yeah.
Tasha: 蛋清蛋黄不能分离了哦
Tasha: The egg white and yolk can't be separated.
Katrina:  你买那个就是分离蛋清
Katrina: You bought the egg white separator.
Tasha: 分离蛋清气不好用哦
Tasha: The egg white separator isn't good.
Katrina:  我之前看那个综艺谁
Katrina: I saw on that variety show...
Katrina:  我也不太会打蛋了
Katrina: I'm also not good at beating eggs.
Tasha: 好那下一次吧
Tasha: Okay, next time then.
Alice: 嗯又又又又变成这个了
Alice: Hmm, it turned into this again.
Tasha:: 呃我算了
Tasha: Ugh, forget it.
Katrina:  哇好像个实验台
Katrina: Wow, it looks like a lab.
Lucia: 那我们这个
Lucia: So this...
Lucia: 哈哈这个蛋蛋他怎么办
Lucia: Haha, what do we do with this egg?
Lucia: 要不炒了吧
Lucia: Should we just scramble it?
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Tasha: 那就每次都倒进去
Tasha: Then pour it in each time.
Tasha: 下一个鸡蛋
Tasha: The next egg.
Lucia: 下一个鸡蛋
Lucia: The next egg.
Tasha: 再拿两
Tasha: Grab two more.
Tasha: 啊在那里
Tasha: Oh, there.
Tasha: 在那里
Tasha: Over there.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈惨遭滑铁卢的经验
Katrina: Hahaha, what a Waterloo experience.
Lucia: 磕丹磕丹磕得太用力了
Lucia: You were grinding too hard.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 那我们先
Lucia: So we...
Katrina: 炒吧
Katrina: Let's stir-fry.
Tasha: 把那个把那个午饭盒子拿过来
Tasha: Bring that lunchbox over here.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Haha, oh my.
Lucia: 啊里面的午餐肉呢
Lucia: Ah, where's the luncheon meat inside?
Lucia: 我们是做别的菜用了吗
Lucia: Did we use it for another dish?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 哎所以我们刚才点点点外卖了吗
Lucia: So, did we just order takeout?
Tasha: 点了
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 点了的话那今天再炒个蛋
Lucia: If we did, then let's stir-fry an egg today.
Lucia: 要不我把这蛋给他炒了算了
Lucia: How about I just cook this egg for him?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:因为比较硬
Alice: Because it's quite hard.
Tasha: 简直不敢相信
Tasha: I can hardly believe it.
Tasha: 我要是
Tasha: If I were...
Lucia: 你你那你需要换个手套或者之类的吗
Lucia: Do you need to change gloves or something?
Katrina:  这谁的手机
Katrina: Whose phone is this?
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: It's mine.
Lucia: 我还拿了一个
Lucia: I also took one.
Tasha: i'm Libbo
Tasha: I'm Libbo.
Lucia: 虽然刚才
Lucia: Even though earlier...
Katrina:  多少蛋啊
Katrina: How many eggs?
Katrina:  两盒吗
Katrina: Two boxes?
Lucia: 不知道好像是两盒
Lucia: Not sure, seems like two.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  做做做那个小蛋糕应该还要蛮多的
Katrina: Making those little cakes should need quite a lot.
Lucia: 这次很成功
Lucia: This time was very successful.
Tasha: 哈哈不敢相信
Tasha: Haha, can't believe it.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  好可爱的蛋
Katrina: Such cute eggs.
Tasha: 完了这个蛋清
Tasha: Oh no, this egg white...
Tasha: 嗯就这个也不要
Tasha: Um, just don't use this.
Tasha: 这是上一次打的蛋清
Tasha: This is the egg white from last time.
Tasha:好了
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 那个那样的话没有问题吗
Lucia: Is it okay to do it that way?
Tasha: 嗯对蛋黄里面
Tasha: Um, yes, in the egg yolk.
Tasha: 没关系蛋蛋清里面一定要是纯蛋清
Tasha: It's okay, the egg white has to be pure egg white.
Tasha: 嗯行再拿两个
Tasha: Hmm, okay, grab two more.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 我们今天一共买了多少蛋啊
Alice: How many eggs did we buy today in total?
Tasha: 嗯好吧我们下次买便宜蛋吧哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, okay, next time let's buy cheaper eggs. Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 没关系的
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 没关系，今天肯定是第一次
Tasha: It's fine, this is definitely the first time today.
Katrina:  whoa啊
Katrina: Whoa, ah!
Katrina:  又成功了
Katrina: We did it again!
Tasha: 不敢相信
Tasha: Can't believe it.
Katrina:  好厉害
Katrina: So impressive.
Alice: 好我再重复一次
Alice: Okay, let me repeat it one more time.
Katrina:  好可爱的鸡蛋哦
Katrina: Such cute eggs.
Katrina:  我超级喜欢吃皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: I absolutely love eating congee with preserved egg and lean pork.
Tasha: ok把这个拿到楼上的冰箱
Tasha: Okay, put this in the fridge upstairs.
Katrina:  第一视角的vlog
Katrina: First-person view vlog.
Tasha: 把这个拿到冰箱里面
Tasha: Put this in the fridge.
Tasha: 呃楼上冰箱吧
Tasha: Uh, upstairs fridge.
Tasha: 因为这已经放不下了
Tasha: Because this one is full.
Tasha: 然后冷冻10分钟
Tasha: Then freeze for 10 minutes.
Tasha: 冷藏10分钟
Tasha: Or refrigerate for 10 minutes.
Lucia: 冷藏
Lucia: Refrigerate.
Tasha: 就可以OK了
Tasha: Then it's good to go, okay.
Alice: 我比较讨厌的就是切的皮很乐乐的
Alice: What I dislike the most is cutting the eggs with sticky shells.
Tasha: 是的你很爱自言自语是吗
Tasha: Yeah, you really love talking to yourself, don't you?
Alice: 外国人会觉得我在做黑暗料理
Alice: Foreigners might think I'm making some weird food.
Alice: 通过屏幕就可以尝到的
Alice: You can almost taste it through the screen.
Alice:那种
Alice: That kind of thing.
Alice:我还没亲口尝一他们肯定
Alice: I haven't even tasted it myself yet. They would definitely...
Alice: 会改变这个看法的
Alice: Change their minds after trying it.
Alice: 这个已经解释了很多遍
Alice: I've explained this so many times.
Alice: 他真的很好吃
Alice: It really tastes good.
Alice: 逐渐暴躁起来了
Alice: I'm getting more and more frustrated.
Tasha: 这个是等会要用的
Tasha: This will be used later.
Alice: 讨厌切皮蛋
Alice: I hate cutting century eggs.
Tasha: 居然不够用了
Tasha: It's actually not enough.
Katrina:  哦他有这么多
Katrina: Oh, there's so many.
Alice: 啥东西呀
Alice: What is it?
Tasha: 没有这么多哎
Tasha: There aren't that many.
Tasha: 就放这吧先
Tasha: Just leave it here for now.
Katrina:  绞鸡蛋有什么技巧吗
Katrina: Any tips for beating eggs?
Tasha: 呃绞鸡蛋没有什么技巧
Tasha: Uh, there's no special technique for beating eggs.
Katrina:  我帮你绞吧
Katrina: Let me help you beat them.
Alice: 就同一个方向
Alice: Just beat them in one direction.
Alice: 是同一个方向绞就行了
Alice: Yeah, just keep beating them in one direction.
Katrina:  特别像绞鸡蛋
Katrina: Feels just like beating eggs.
Tasha: 呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, wait a second.
Alice: 你我讨厌红楼梦里
Alice: You know, I hate "Dream of the Red Chamber."
Alice: 你剩那么多
Alice: You left so much.
Tasha: OK擦干   哈哈
Tasha: OK, dry it. Haha.
Lucia: 再擦一遍
Lucia: Dry it again.
Tasha:: 对因为只有一个对吧
Tasha: Yeah, because we only have one, right?
Tasha: 资金有限
Tasha: Limited budget.
Alice: 其实做菜的时候真的没有很满足就是
Alice: Actually, cooking doesn't feel very satisfying.
Alice: 备菜的过程就是在调查
Alice: The prep work is like an investigation.
Tasha: 所以呃
Tasha: So, uh...
Tasha: 所以如果做烘焙的话
Tasha: So if you're baking...
Tasha: 会买那种厨房用纸
Tasha: You should buy those kitchen towels.
Tasha: 可以擦干很多遍的那个
Tasha: The ones you can use many times.
Lucia: 就是那个吸吸吸水纸那种对
Lucia: Yeah, the super absorbent ones, right?
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What’s this?
Lucia: 我以前拿那个光光拿它擦锅灶
Lucia: I used to use it to wipe the stove.
Katrina:  原来还有这个事
Katrina: Oh, I didn't know that.
Katrina:  要做什么来着
Katrina: What are we making again?
Katrina:  就小蛋糕吗
Katrina: Just some small cakes?
Tasha: 嗯就做一个最简单的就行吧
Tasha: Yeah, just something simple.
Katrina:  先打鸡蛋
Katrina: First, beat the eggs.
Katrina:  先乳化
Katrina: Emulsify first.
Alice: 逐渐暴躁
Alice: Getting frustrated.
Alice: 我真的讨厌切皮蛋啊
Alice: I really hate cutting century eggs.
Alice: 先给给我一个筷子啊
Alice: First, give me a chopstick.
Katrina:  这样就这样吧
Katrina: Like this, just like this.
Katrina:  好保持平静
Katrina: Okay, stay calm.
Alice: 心情平静
Alice: Stay calm.
Katrina:  这个是只需要蛋黄
Katrina: We just need the egg yolk for this.
Tasha: 对用蛋黄
Tasha: Yeah, just the yolk.
Lucia: 好像应该
Lucia: It seems like...
Lucia: 我觉得差不多了
Lucia: I think it's enough.
Lucia: 不过外面还有点水小心
Lucia: But there's still some water outside, be careful.
Tasha: 然后加28克的玉米油
Tasha: Then add 28 grams of corn oil.
Alice: 你说讨厌红楼梦里  恶心
Alice: You said you hate "Dream of the Red Chamber," it's disgusting.
Katrina:  放点歌吧
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Alice: 大东北
Alice: Northeast China.
Katrina:  我知道你刚刚唱那首歌
Katrina: I know the song you just sang.
Katrina:  是不是讨厌红楼梦
Katrina: Is it because you hate "Dream of the Red Chamber"?
Alice: 对对对哎呀天呐
Alice: Yes, yes, oh my god.
Alice: 受不了了
Alice: I can't stand it.
Katrina:  天啊
Katrina: Oh my god.
Alice: 讨厌红楼梦
Alice: I hate "Dream of the Red Chamber."